thanks jillian well you can't buy
happiness but you can buy chocolate and
that makes very
many people happy and getting chocolate
this valentine's day will make it extra
sweet joining me now is chef and owner
of jean-marie abwan chocolatier
jean-marie welcome thank you thank you
mr for having me thank you for being
here and when it comes to chocolate it
pretty much doesn't matter to me what it
looks like but these are the most
beautiful chocolates and now i don't
think i'll ever go back to
not good looking chocolate this is
beautiful these are special valentine's
day packs that you created tell us a
little bit about that yes we have a lot
of different options actually we put a
lot of love to make this chocolate and
we have different options and especially
also very very
unique item and a limited edition for
example all the hearts as you can see
the red one it's actually a homemade
peanut butter which is just a peanut
butter roasted a little bit salt after
that we have a passion fruit one which
is very creamy ganache with the passion
fruit inside this one it's a very
specific vanillite vanilla titan teeth
from tidy which is island
this one absolutely this one is quite
very very intense in flavor very very
warm and this one is like biting in a
strawberry it's a strawberry and cream
it's very very
uh rich and rich in fruit it's very
interesting it's a good balance and we
have a lot of different boxes for
example here 16 boxes only out or this
one is a 40 pieces box there's a lot of
different options a lot of possibility
also to customize your box when you come
to our showroom and that's make that
very very unique now if you're going to
buy chocolates for your loved one for
valentine's day these are the kind you
want to give them you don't want to show
up with any you know low end these are
the
best ingredients quality ingredients and
obviously they look beautiful now you
guys are located on harmon right harmon
in decatur that's correct yes and i
understand you have special hours
because it's valentine's day and so many
people are going to be scrambling tell
me a little bit about when you're open
we are open on saturday actually until 7
p.m and we are open a little bit a
little bit late as well at night around
6 or 7 p.m as well where people can can
stop by and we can really also what is
important people can test the product
what is
what i recommend to to our customers
it's actually to stop by test the
product and after that we can build a
box we have already boxes pre-built as
well and pre uh
presets now don't mind if i do you said
to test the product um i've i heard that
this specific one here has won an award
yes tell us what this is we won an award
it's actually we call that double sea
salt
because you have two layers
actually with double sea salt caramel we
have two layers of caramel inside dare i
taste please do oh my i'm so excited
okay
and we won an award with the new york
times a few years ago
man that is that's the double
the double layer in there yes double sea
salt caramel
it's a double layer of caramel which is
one chili caramel and one creamy caramel
in the same actually chocolate that is
the most amazing sea salt caramel i
think i've ever had in my life my
goodness okay so you can get boxes with
the small boxes the large boxes and
how long will these be available for
well only until valentine's all the
hearts actually after that end times
they don't exist anymore because we we
make the product fresh there's no
preservative inside and and we want to
keep it that way what's your favorite
all of them
that's a great answer i'll take one of
each please
i cannot wait to
indulge in some more of these so if you
want to check it out jean-marie avon
chocolatier again where are you located
and on aman indicator you definitely
have to check them out your valentine or
your galentine or your kids they will
definitely thank you i'll send it over
to you now